[Musica]
buonasera
signore e signori amici grazie grazie a
tutti
beh lo avete sentito il mondo di prima
era più facile
questa è una cartina geopolitica del
mondo prima della caduta del muro
vedete evidenziata in rosso la cortina
di ferro questa fu tanti di noi lo
ricorderanno la fulminea e straordinaria
intuizione barra definizione di wiston
churchill ora uno dice wiston churchill
uno degli eroi del ventesimo secolo non
solo dei nostri tempi
uno dei padri della libertà per tutti
noi però che funga da monito per
cominciare questa nostra chiacchierata
anche se a parlare solo io e da solo ho
la speranza che si generi comunque uno
scambio tra di noi e anche soltanto
ideale impatti come ci sarà non ho dubbi
ebbene servì stone churchill
l'uomo che sconfisse contribuire a
sconfiggere il mostro nazista il
vincitore uno dei vincitori della
seconda guerra mondiale l'uomo che da
solo davanti alla follia nazista non
aveva pensato neanche per un istante per
render sebbene voi sapete che cosa
accadde alla fine della guerra
passati pochi mesi il grande uomo
vittore tutto quello che ho detto
fu mandato a casa dai suoi lettori
monito ma torniamo a noi torniamo a
quella cartina torniamo al mondo di
prima che era come detto più facile i
cattivi erano tutti di là i buoni noi
eravamo tutti di qua era facile
schierarsi nascevamo già schierati ora
c'è da dire che anche in italia molti
pubblicamente in realtà sostenevano di
sognare l'altra parte quelli al di là
della cortina di ferro ma tranquilli lo
facevano pubblicamente in privato
pochissimi praticamente nessuno fino a
quando addirittura il segretario del
partito comunista italiano enrico
berlinguer confessò di sentirsi molto
più tranquillo sotto l'ombrello della
nato
ossia degli americani quelli che negli
anni settanta in molti scrivevano con la
k come così glee è questo dunque il
mondo di prima in cui era facile
posizionarsi
ripeto nascevamo già schierati e
posizionati 1989 viene giù il muro
guardate quel sistema quello del
socialismo reale era marcio fino alle
fondamenta da una vita lo sapevamo tutti
mi permetto di parlare in prima pura le
perché c'ero si era un ragazzino ma
insomma lo sapevamo
ne eravamo consapevoli ma nessuno si
sarebbe mai immaginato la repentina
caduta del muro
nell 89 ovviamente questa non è una
cartina del fanta tante cose sono
accadute però è molto utile perché oltre
all'estrema complessità non c'è più la
linea rossa della cortina di ferro ma
sono esplosi paesino con tutto ciò che
ne è conseguito anche nel nostro
continente
nel mentre accadono due cose all'inizio
e noi siamo gli occidentali sia coloro
che hanno vinto la guerra fredda
l'avevamo definita fredda mentre ancora
la combattevamo poi non fu sempre fredda
ad essere onesti fu anche calda in vari
territori e terreni ma lontani anche
geograficamente da noi abbiamo vinto
l'occidente ha vinto il socialismo reale
si dissolve implode letteralmente è
addirittura uno studioso americano
francis fukuyama lo ricorderete arrivo a
teorizzare la fine della storia
quanti hanno citato fukuyama perché poi
una bella frase no la fine della storia
non intendeva che sarebbe finita come
poteva intenderlo è una testa
meravigliosa l'evolversi della storia
umana no lui intendeva dire che le
organizzazioni statali parlava nei primi
90 naturalmente sarebbero andati tutti
ad evolvere verso la democrazia liberale
sappiamo che non è andata esattamente
così per qualche anno ci siamo illusi
poi e poi passando dalla data fondante
della nostra generazione che è e resterà
sempre una la 11 settembre 2001 abbiamo
scoperto la paura
esattamente come abbiamo sentito poco fa
paure inafferrabili eppure estremamente
concrete terrore
altro che paura e con la paura
l'insicurezza e con l'insicurezza un
fenomeno la nostalgia la nostalgia di
cosa
e qui è divertente perché questo
fenomeno ha coinvolto adesso ve lo
spiego ma ha coinvolto un sacco di
persone che sono arrivate dopo sono nate
dopo o semplicemente erano così piccole
da non poter ricordare il mondo di prima
quello con la cortina di ferro
la nostalgia del mondo di prima quello
facile quello in cui ti sceglievi amici
e nemici o almeno non troppo amici
perché poi in realtà i mondi si
parlavano grazie al cielo anche allora
la nostalgia di un mondo che in realtà
non è mai esistito perché era signore il
mondo del terrore atomico dimenticato ed
oggi è complicato prima era facile
nostalgia nostalgia che funziona come ci
siamo è arrivato il freddo stavo dicendo
il frescolino ammazza cioè stamattina mi
sono svegliato 8 gradi a milano e qui
credo che più o meno march assimo nelle
stesse sulle stesse misure e allora
quando arrivano i primi freddi e voglia
di starsene a casa
metti la copertina la ritiri fuori
dall'armadio è finita la bella stagione
metti sul film che non magari quello che
vi sto già tre volte
ormai è come è venuta un'espressione
d'altri tempi il ventesimo secolo metti
su oggi lo mettiamo su più niente
scegliamo ovviamente il servizio
streaming ma comunque vai magari a
sceglierti quel film che ha visto
rivisto perché la nostalgia ti porta a
voler rivedere non vedere allo stadio ti
coccola blandisce ti fa star tranquillo
ti dà il tepore della copertina ne hai
bisogno perché questo mondo ti fa paura
questo mondo ti sfugge questo mondo è
pieno di incertezze questo mondo anche
prima della pandemia era dominato da e
adesso che succede
la nostalgia ti aiuta ma da sola non
servirebbe senza una rivisitazione della
nostra realtà
pensiamoci un attimo e questo è un
passaggio fondamentale non esiste
un'altra era della storia in cui siamo
riusciti in così pochi anni ad abbattere
a livello globale la povertà e la fame
non esiste non esiste un'altra era in
cui ci siamo posti quotidianamente il
tema vi faccio questo esempio perché va
di moda della differenza di genere non è
mai esistito eppure sembra che no non
conti non ho detto che non esista più la
povertà
qualcuno l'ha detto ha portato sfiga ma
non è quello il problema
a sostare a se stesso ovviamente il tema
non è quello e che oggettivamente
abbiamo meno persone che muoiono di fame
rispetto a pochi anni fa e questo è un
effetto della globalizzazione eppure se
tu dici globalizzazione in pubblico urli
globalizzazione
magari qualcuno ti manda a quel paese
non sa perché ma lo fa perché va di moda
perché il mondo di oggi verranno
raccontato come un mondo che vi frega un
mondo che è il racconto è stato fatto
contro di voi
per realizzare questo è bene hai bisogno
di una potente arma comunicativa
prima di arrivare a quei luoghi che
conosciamo tutti che sono parte della
nostra esistenza
dobbiamo parlare di semplificazione
perché ottenere per ottenere lo
stravolgimento della realtà per
raccontarvi che il mondo che stiamo
vivendo
se poi difetti ci mancherebbe ma non
certo il peggiore possibile vi ho fatto
due esempi rapidi potrei andare avanti
per mezz'ora è in realtà il peggiore è
soprattutto un mondo che non vi dà più
garanzie di futuro
di che cosa hanno bisogno i rem è stato
re del torbido di semplificare oltre
ogni misura e non spiegarvi più nulla
la geopolitica di cui sopra ridotta a un
tweet grazie al cielo ci hanno dato 280
caratteri perché fino a poco fa eravamo
a 140 uno slogan magari una serie di
slogan di grandissimo effetto di grande
impatto ma di nessuna realtà storica
servono a semplificare oltremodo una
realtà semplice una realtà compattata in
un bel pacchettino con un fiocco che vi
viene servita questa è la realtà vi
stanno fregando vi stanno rubando il
futuro quante volte avete sentito questa
frase vi stanno rubando il futuro in
genere viene detto con un atteggiamento
di sofferenza fisica perché sennò non
vale ora semplificazione fermi tutti
questi sono sicuramente dei veicoli di
disinformazione ma parla uno che ama i
social usa i social lavora con i social
vive nei social non solo evidentemente
ma anche però attenzione sono strumenti
per la loro natura talmente potenti da
dover essere conosciuti
studio ci torneremo fra pochissimo
quindi ecco cipro dati a quelli a che
globalmente viene definito il fenomeno
delle fake nelle fake news ma le fake di
per sé non funzionerebbe se non ci fosse
quel progetto di mistificazione della
realtà spesso le fei che sono così fake
che insomma da sole non si leggerebbero
in piedi ma se prima c'è stato tutto
quel lavorio per cui vi hanno raccontato
che la vostra realtà di oggi in realtà è
una grande fregatura ordita dal eminenze
grigie dalle anime nere se vogliamo
giocare con i colori ed è ovvio che
viene più facile credere all'impossibile
alle baggianate più clamorose quelle che
da sole esploderebbero perché proprio
non stanno in piedi ma in un contesto
mistificato e invece le due cose possono
andare in qualche modo di pari passo
vi ho parlato di evidenze grigie
un'altra grande moda ma la moda delle
mode quale le élite quando tutto manca
quando non si riesce a spiegare nulla di
ciò che accade nel nostro mondo che un
mondo estremamente complesso e questo è
un fatto molto più complesso di prima
quando non sanno più che cosa
raccontarvi tirano fuori le élite
l'elite chi sono
stringiamo al massimo quelli che hanno
studiato ed eccoci tornati al punto
nessuno di noi può oggi a qualsiasi età
andarsene in giro come capitava voglio
dire io l'ho sentito dei miei genitori
in due hanno tre lauree è però si
potevano permettere di dire un certo
punto hanno ma questa cosa io non la
capisco oggi cari amici non ce lo
possiamo più permettere perché noi
abbiamo una missione quella di
contrastare ciascuno per la nostra parte
tutto ciò che ho provato a raccontare è
una missione è una missione fatta di
impegno quotidiano fatto in presenza
come grazie al cielo abbiamo potuto fare
questa sera fatto online i social per
contrastare le fake news
non ci può andar bene non vi può andare
bene la mistificazione continua quindi
sta a voi per stare a voi però dovete
studiare impegnarvi i social van
presi ogni social ha un suo linguaggio
una sua grammatica è se lo vogliamo se
vogliamo usare non solo per il
divertimento che è assolutamente
benvenuto ma anche per evolvere come
comunità
dobbiamo capire cosa stiamo dicendo agli
altri come lo stiamo facendo
guardate non è un passatempo è qualcosa
che chiama il nostro senso di
responsabilità altrimenti avranno vinto
quelli di prima e non ce lo possiamo
assolutamente consentire perché vedete
quando coloro che si sono maggiormente
impegnati vengono sbrigativamente
definite elite
sapete che cosa succede che la
dottoressa carlotta che mi ha preceduto
peraltro facendovi sentire piuttosto
superfluo devo dire
lei ha raccontato delle dei suoi
successi che sono straordinari ma non
perché non la conosco l'ho vista per la
prima volta questa sera su questo papa
mi sono rimasto assolutamente
affascinato come son certo voi non ha
raccontato quello perché è dotata di un
ego ipertrofico perché deve mostrarsi
gonfiarsi e quindi star lì sui suoi
riconoscimenti no perché una persona che
ha raggiunto grandi risultati
sudando faticando studiando anche
insieme agli altri sa perfettamente di
essere pronta come la dottoressa
carlotta mettere a disposizione i propri
talenti della comunità questa è la
vittoria più grande che ci può essere
che la vittoria che mette fuori gioco
istantaneamente tutti coloro che ci
vorrebbero definire una massa indistinta
i grandi difensori del popolo delle
masse sottoposte al gioco dell'uomo nero
dell'eminenza grigia e dell'elite alla
fine considerano poi noi né pecoroni non
male come voglio dire giudizio di coloro
che ci dovrebbero difendere e allora
mentre avremmo bisogno di uno cento
mille esempi come la dottoressa carlotta
però ciascuno di noi deve fare qualcosa
questa è una pagina di ricerca caduta
del muro di berlino di google non
fermarsi
mai al primo risultato è banale ma è un
esempio
wikipedia non ho nulla contro wikipedia
ma per un pezzo di mondo mica solo noi
italiani ormai il sapere e wikipedia
lunga vita a wikipedia sono un
contributore di wikipedia ma c'è ragazzi
vi assicuro c'è un mondo oltre la prima
pagina delle ricerche di google
esiste la seconda e la terza che in
realtà su una sorta di limbo online però
sta a noi è un impegno costa fatica ci
vuole tempo e più facile andare su
wikipedia lo so me ne rendo conto ma non
basta
e incredibile che nell'era in cui
abbiamo a disposizione una massa di dati
come mai nessuno nella storia nessuno
quando qualcuno vi dice ai miei tempi
per cortesia mandate a quel paese perché
ai miei tempi quelli con i soldi avevano
la treccani quelli senza soldi si
dovevano arrangiare quelli con
pochissimo ci avevano se andava bene il
nonno
adesso ognuno di voi alla biblioteca di
alessandria nello smartphone e questa è
una responsabilità perché questa fortuna
ce la dobbiamo meritare lavorando
faticando studiando quindi mai fermarsi
mai fermarsi per farlo beh guardate se
non avete un bambino fatti per i sitter
mettetevi lì con loro
state con loro osservateli non è
necessario essere dei matti come me che
alla mia età ne ha 21 che ancora in
fasce e l'altro che va all'asilo
no non è necessario essere completamente
pazzi però è sufficiente fare baby
sitter guardateli guardate gli occhi di
un bambino quando osserva il mondo il
mondo che anche la sua cameretta e la
mamma il papà e il gioco il primo gioco
che riesco i suoi occhi riesce a
cogliere a focalizzare a tre mesi è la
vita che si schiude e la curiosità verso
il mondo lì noi siamo tenuti a restare
perché guardate e qui mi fermo
prima di tutto quello che ci è accaduto
la notte degli oscar
vi ricordate ha vinto para site film
sudcoreano e molti in america hanno
detto
oddio ha vinto un film sudcoreana che
bei tempi quando vinceva via col vento
questo è un fenomeno antico è già su ci
siamo già passati classicismo ma
soprattutto manierismo per un po
furono scambiati come l'unico modo di
fare ancora arte perché si pensava che
fosse stato fatto tutto ovviamente non
era vero è arrivato qualcuno dopo il
manierismo
però allora molti si fermarono lì perché
perché quella era una gigantesca comfort
zone per donne e uomini di minor talento
e che avevano terminato i loro sogni
buona serata